I was traveling with a woman who was
studying the transmission of month pox
and monkey pox is really dreadful
disease in the case of nor bear or the
young man in the photograph it was a
profoundly disturbing case a number of
months later he he died I think that
people don't understand when they see
photographs that are disturbing they
don't understand that you are in large
part powerless to change the fate of
that person there are some people you
just have a connection with that you
meet in the field because you know that
they're consciously making a
contribution and allowing you to be
present in their life and to photograph
them even though they are at their
smallest their weakest their saddest and
that's an act of courage